[Music]
wowza that's fantastic
okay
how are we doing good how are you doing
how are you doing gotcha good here we go
[Music]
daddy
hi i'm alyssa and i'm itoki and this is
expert amateur fraud the show where we
try to figure out who the expert is and
who's faking it and today we're going to
be interviewing three
goldberg who do we have
oh
tattoo artists
okay do you have tattoos i don't have
any tattoos nor do i okay
hi
so whoever you guys think is the expert
will be tattooing me
oh
my god
that's a lot more pressure now this is
terrifying we're usually goofing and
gaffing
as you will i have all the confidence in
both of you so awesome
no pressure you shouldn't
[Music]
hello
well thanks for having us welcome hello
what's your name i'm xyla xyla also
known as bloodlust as my artist name so
these are coil machines okay um they're
known as like the more
popular old-school machines so what
makes it a coil machine is they have
these two coils that are right over here
this is your front
coil and that's your back coil and then
these are
tubes and then needles which we won't be
opening since this is in a licensed
establishment and we don't want to prick
anybody yet
the reason why i love uh tattooing is
because i've always wanted to find a
career path which involved my talents
you have a lot of tattoos i don't i
noticed a lot of them i have this says
dusk and dawn and then this is living on
a prayer the bon jovi song
a werewolf oh that's dope and then of
course my moon did you do any of these
yourself though no um i don't really
believe in putting like
tattoos on myself due to the fact that i
just know that if i do one day i might
regret it i'd rather have somebody like
professional do it
i mean i'm a professional as well but
i'd rather have like somebody that i'm
like collecting art from do it for me
gotcha oh very cool
what did you think about xyla
i just have this feeling that she's like
here to throw us off i don't know face
tattoo most of the faces are that is
true known are probably also tattoo
artists what are you talking about
yeah that's true
hello what's up hi tiffany nice to meet
you guys nice to meet you i have a
bluetooth stencil printer and ink um
i was kind of lazy i didn't really want
to bring all my stuff today so you would
just like print off
yeah like i'll print out yeah and then
and then lay it out on
the customer and then peel it off and
then make sure that the outline is all
set up and then that's when we start
tattooing okay you actually have some
fresh ones yeah i did that last night
you can't really stop they're very
addicting and it feels very freeing too
honestly what's the oddest request
you've ever had from a client i've had
like requests before where people would
ask for scriptures and i just wouldn't
really take it just because it's not my
style so it's not really like odd but
it's just something i like refuse
because it's like i'm not gonna put my
heart and soul into that it's not gonna
be really you know special for them so i
appreciate that if you're doing
something that you're not really like
into that might kind of like that energy
might be a tattoo yeah right
sorry i forgot i was wearing these
gloves
kind of feel like a superhero
and this is the ink you use yeah okay
yeah okay can we take a look yeah sure
do you i've noticed you only have black
do you ever do other colors you only do
black oh you're just black yeah that's
your style
tiffany knew that she was having this
shoot today do you think that was part
of her plan be like yeah these are
friends i want to trust her and say that
she she did her own tattoos but if she
did and those are
mad professionals and she has this
maybe her friend has it that means she
borrowed it what kind of a
unless they gave it to him on the show
did you
did you guys see that you sickos
my name is christian nice to meet you
christian
hey what did you bring but this is
actually a rotary machine and since you
guys are gloved up you can go ahead and
take a look at it okay it's just a
picture
that's really cool i don't even know
which side is which yeah i don't either
right here is where you look like a
dildo
i'm like a boomer sometimes
my jokes
don't say
[Applause]
is there anything that you wouldn't do
at all like there's something that's
something you feel morally wrong you
know doing
uh
uh maybe genitalia
okay maybe have been like tattooing
genitalia or tattooing genitalia on
people
yeah yes both
[Laughter]
what about if like two people came in
has this ever happened and they're like
we just met we're in love
like we want to get tats of each other's
names i'd walk over in the corner laugh
a little bit come back and i'd be like
all right yeah sure really okay and then
you do it small enough so that when they
come back to get it covered up then you
can cover it up got it do you do a lot
of cover ups oh yeah
you seem really level-headed the
opposite of me
you're like very healthy with your
thinking it can be a stressful job so
it's good to just be calm keep cool
because you deal with a lot of people as
i've tattooed and tattooed for years and
years i just kind of found kind of a zen
with uh just kind of breathing and you
just kind of think about the moment okay
so i want to check out some of your
tattoos yeah i just right now i just got
some of my hand stuff out but you know
it's a lot of movie stuff a lot of like
uh star wars and things like that and
you do a lot yourself or no no never
touched myself oh cool okay and i think
everyone can kind of answer this tattoos
kind of taboo right like general society
especially the ones that are visible say
like face tattoos like your moon and
some of the ones you saw what would you
say to those people
deal with it
also like
you know people discriminate against you
just having visible tattoos or they make
assumptions that you've gone to prison
but a long time ago people used to get
tattooed just to
you know recognize what tribe you're
from absolutely yeah you should talk to
my mom about it
is my mom my mom's asian too so yeah she
did the whole tattoo thing but i'm sorry
girl
thank you all so much um it was a
pleasure talking to you all getting to
know you and
god bless you all
okay so you've gotten a tattoo yes
did any of them kind of give you like oh
yeah that's the vibe of a tattoo artist
did you get that
i mean this is not helpful but they all
kind of did because
normally people i've gone to have been
super chill laid back and they all
seemed
really chill okay
let's start with expert gut instinct
boom three two one
awesome
christian though like i said he was
calming right we all felt it was around
him yeah when i think about a tattoo
artist they might just kind of be like
quiet like hey man just let me let me
put that thing on your arm dude great
and i feel like
tiffany and christian had more of that
vibe so you think zile is the problem
that's what i was gonna say as well
and and never thought that
what were you thinking yeah i thought
xylo expert
really because of the old school
machine that's right i watched a youtube
video about like a spy
talking about how to spot a wire
and the one person that kind of seemed
to be like turning away and not really
engaging was um
tiffany a little bit avoiding some
things from this spy video
okay do you think tiffany with the
amateur
she got into the whole stencil-making
process a little bit um and saying that
she doesn't like to do scriptures that's
right which is it's a pretty likely
story that's kind of an interesting
thing
and maybe xyla is a fraud they kept
talking about like people think that if
you have tattoos that means you're in
prison that might be an old it's a
traditional music so maybe xyla
is a lover of tattoos and a huge like
proponent for tattoos but that doesn't
necessarily mean they're an artist i'm
freaking out though because i like
literally two minutes ago thought xyla
was the expert
how do you feel
i'm still excited but i'm i'm nervous
now like yeah it's real it's about to
happen so now we're going to bring back
our tattoo artist welcome
welcome back
this was hard actually to be honest i
know you might think they say that every
time but it literally felt like an hour
deliberation xyla
we think
you are the fraud
we thought you knew a lot about tattoos
you obviously have some amazing tattoos
but we thought maybe you were kind of
talking about it in a way that was like
trying to trick us
i freaking knew it
i knew it i knew it
are you okay bridgette yeah i mean
that's one down
this next one's important tiffany hello
there we thought you were the amateur
it seems like you're pretty
knowledgeable about tattoos it seems
like you have clients
yeah this the specific examples of like
what you won't do yeah you know uh but
maybe it's more of like a side hustle i
don't know that's kind of reasoning very
calm and collected but yeah maybe you're
um just getting into it anyways we're
obviously probably wrong but uh
three
two
one
oh my god what does this mean
this is
terrifying best case scenario
christian
is not the fraud yeah all right
what we're gonna do
had two is
before we know oh before we know oh
my god
[Music]
how do you feel
i'll get back to you
oh my gosh she's the freaking fraud
are you joking well
there's the tools that you had out
and are they his tools that's valid yeah
how are you
i'm good good good good that's good
that's right it's good that we're both
good right now
right now yes later yes i will also be
good
water
okay
how are we doing good how are you doing
how are you doing gotcha good now this
is normal i do this all the time
okay okay
okay before you do it though are you
sure
me are you guys sure yeah wait what what
do you mean does he need to sanitize or
something no alcohol
so if a fraud was giving a tattoo i
would be a hundred percent worried about
contamination um bloodborne pathogens
and
also if that person really knows how to
operate a tattoo machine
okay bridgette here we go
here we go
in the skin
there we go
look at that
how you feeling all done that's good
we're all done
do another line
go for it okay i mean that one
looks pretty good yeah all right yeah
there we go
how are you guys feeling over there my
heart is pounding yeah
oh my bad
[Music]
you're good at lines
so yeah i am the expert
wow
you know growing up i just grew up as an
artist and didn't really know where i
wanted to go my sister started jumping
into the tattoo game and so she invited
me to get into a shop with her so i did
i started tattooing and i found that
it's the best thing for me so you're
you're amateur
i'm actually an apprentice um for two
years now because i moved to riverside
now i'm going to be transferring over
either opening my own little shop or
continuing my apprenticeship that's
amazing
and you're fraught i that's what i said
but i said i thought you were the frog
because i was like great loves her tats
but i don't know i was like she didn't
talk much i i literally spent 10 hours
with my tattoo a tattoo artist yesterday
literally like i know his entire back
story and memorized it for this moment
that's what i remember i was like maybe
she just got some tattoos for this shoot
like to be like yeah i just wasn't doing
it i really actually did i thought for
this video oh no no no i just wanted
extra so i got five yesterday i actually
started getting tattoos um
like six months ago i have 20 now how's
it going bridgette you feeling good i
feel really good i am really proud of
all of us
this is great thank you guys so much for
watching i mean i feel so much better i
do too it was actually so so stressful i
was having an emotional reaction and
thinking that we just like
what did we do we really want to hear
your comments what you thought did you
know were you freaked out
you